Dave: Zalando is Europe's
leading
online fashion destination,
now transforming into a
multiservice fashion platform.
We are based out of Berlin,
and we have offices across
several European cities.
We are present in 15 European
countries at the moment,
and we boast 1500 brands on
our online fashion platform.
70% of our site traffic
comes via mobile devices,
so we are innovating
the mobile experience
for our users
further and further.
We launched photo search as well
as barcode scanner
to bridge this gap between
online and offline
fashion books.
We also have certain features,
for example,
garden wish list sync,
which provides a seamless
cross platform experience.
The high-quality app experience
can make or break
the customer journey.
We invested a lot to improve
user experience
and the app quality
for our Android apps.
We saw around 6% increase
on a monthly basis last year
in our app installs.
We get around 40% of
our Android app installs
via organic traffic.
We also saw increase
in our lifetime value,
which we measure by
revenue per user.
And we saw 15% increase on a
quarterly basis last quarter.
Riera: We have been working in
several fronts
to improve app quality.
We did a huge refactor
in our [inaudible]
and strengthen technical
formation.
We also add more and more
test information,
as well as a regression test
to be sure
that the app quality is intact
on every release.
There are several tools
in the Google Play console
that really helps us to ensure
the app quality.
Alpha and beta testing, as well
as pre-launch reports.
The new release dashboard,
it's a powerful tool
which improves the app
distribution.
It gives us all the data
with a bunch of metrics,
as in upgrades,
crashes, ratings.
That helps us to monitoring
[inaudible] very closely.
Since we improved quality,
we decrease the app start time
by around 30%,
and we reduced the daily average
crashes
by up to 90%.
Regarding ratings, we improved
from 4.3 to 4.4,
which indicates that user
satisfaction is growing.
Dave: We have invested a lot
in developing
great customer experience
in our Android apps,
and we have achieved many great
milestones out of it.
As a product manager,
this motivates me
to deliver great
mobile experience
for our Android users.